in baden-Württembergs Ministerpräsident
Winfried Kretschmann hat sich für eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht im Kampf gegen
das Coronavirus ausgesprochen in einem
Gastbeitrag für die Frankfurter
Allgemeine Zeitung schrieb der grünen
Politiker gemeinsam mit Bayerns
Regierungschef Markus Söder eine
Impfpflicht ist kein Verstoß gegen die
Freiheitsrechte vielmehr ist sie die
Voraussetzung dafür dass wir unsere
Freiheit zurückgewinnen bei uns im
Studio ist bildpolitikchef Jan Schäfer
fliegender Wechsel hier immer bei uns im
Studio da wo Kali Underberg gerade noch
stand ja also ist das sozusagen der
Durchbruch für die Impfpflicht nein das
ist natürlich noch nicht der Durchbruch
denn es handelt sich hier um den
Ministerpräsidenten von
Baden-Württemberg also nochmal es ist
nicht der Durchbruch denn es handelt
sich um den Ministerpräsidenten von
Baden-Württemberg den einzigen den die
Grünen haben aber natürlich ist er eine
gewichtige Stimme wir wissen dass es
beispielsweise auf Seiten der FDP ganz
ganz viel Widerstand gegen eine
allgemeine im gibt auch Olaf Scholz hat
sich in letzter Zeit immer noch sehr
sehr zurückhaltend geäußert wir wissen
aber auch beispielsweise von Robert
Habeck der schon im letzten Jahr gesagt
hat wenn sich nicht genügend Menschen
freiwillig impfen lassen würden dann
müsste es halt eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht gegen geben in dieses Horn
stößt du auch Winfried Kretschmann und
wir wissen auch von heute Vormittag dass
der CSU-Vorstand um Markus Söder ja
gesagt hat das müsste in Deutschland
eine allgemeine Impfpflicht geben also
die Debatte ist in vollem Gange aber die
ampelparteien die sind dann noch sehr
sehr unterschiedlicher Meinung geimpft
gelesen oder gestorben wir sehen es äh
hier hinter uns der Ausspruch von Jens
Spahn heute morgen er hat selbst dazu
gesagt dass Mark zynisch klingen wollte
es auf die Spitze treiben im Moment wenn
ich richtig informiert bin Tagen die
Gesundheitsminister der Länder dauert
die Konferenz noch an es gibt eine
Beschlussvorlage du hast schon mal
reingeschaut genau wir wissen eigentlich
die Beschlussvorlage ist jetzt auch ein
Beschluss die 16 Gesundheitsminister
Bundesländer die haben getagt und wir
sehen hier unter anderem ein Ergebnis
dieses Gipfels dieses regelmäßig Tagen
in Gremiums ein das Bundesministerium
für Gesundheit wird aufgefordert alles
zu tun um die Impfungen mit dem
Impfstoff von biontech Pfizer weiterhin
im vollem Umfang zu ermöglichen den
Impfstoff von biontech Pfizer im Rahmen
der Regelversorgung unverzüglich
bereitzustellen sowie die vorhandenen
Lagerbestände so weit wie möglich rasch
auszuliefern unseren Informationen ist
dieser Beschluss auch am Ende mit 16 zu
0 Stimmen durchgegangen das heißt da gab
es jetzt schon eine deutliche Watschen
auch für Jens Spahn der ja äh eine
Rationierung von biontec Impfstoff für
die nächsten Wochen verfügt hat einfach
gesagt es ist einfach nicht genug da wie
kann man dann so eine Aufforderung
machen wenn es tatsächlich praktische
Probleme gibt nein es gibt die
Aufforderung der 16 Gesundheitsminister
der Länder dass sie entspannt alles tun
muss um den die verfügbare Menge an
biontech-impfstoff deutlich zu erhöhen
also er soll nicht nur mit dem
Unternehmen die selbst sprechen er soll
auch versuchen über die europäische
Ebene noch an zusätzlichen Impfstoff
heranzukommen das ist der Auftrag der
formuliert worden wurde und die 16
Gesundheitsminister der Länder die
heißen ist auch nicht gut dass sie in
Spanien nicht entsprechend vorgesorgt
hat ja wir wollen noch mal einmal
reinhören in das was Jens Spahn nämlich
heute morgen gesagt hat da ging es ja
eben genau um diese Impfung und wie es
über den Winter heraus aussehen könnte
was zum zweiten Jahr bleibt ist einen
Umstand den wir schon seit Monaten
beschreiben wahrscheinlich wird am Ende
dieses Winters
so ziemlich jeder in Deutschland
wo der manchmal schon etwas zynisch
genannt geimpft gewesen oder gestorben
sein
haben es ja gerade schon gesagt geimpft
gelesen oder gestorben das sind schon
harte Worte muss es denn jetzt auch
solche harten Worte geben das ist jetzt
eben weitergeht in der Bekämpfung der
coronakrise wir hören das ja immer
wieder diese Vergleiche wir erinnern uns
an Markus Söder der auch mal sagte hier
jeden Tag stürzt in Deutschland ein
Flugzeug voll besetzt ab und wollte
damit auch auf die Todeszahlen Hinweisen
jetzt also so ein Satz von Jens Spahn
das sind immer wieder diese Vergleiche
die Politiker ziehen einerseits um Angst
zu machen offenbar aber um gleichzeitig
auch von politischem Versagen abzulenken
denn es ist ja interessant dass
eigentlich diese Impfkampagne schon vor
Monaten ins Stocken geraten ist und Jens
Spahn eigentlich so gut wie gar nichts
unternommen hat um dieser Impfkampagne
neues Leben einzuhauchen jetzt stellen
wir fest plötzlich steigen die Zahlen
derjenigen die sich impfen lassen wollen
und angebliches plötzlich gar nicht
genug Impfstoff da also da passt ja
einiges nicht zusammen und dann zu sagen
ja entweder seid ihr am Ende dieses
Winters nämlich im März oder April alle
geimpft wir sind alle genesen oder die
die nicht Genesung geimpft sind sind
alle tot das ist ja ein
versagenseingeständnis für die eigene
Politik Jan Schäfer danke für die
Einordnung